welcome to the realm where vigilance
needs Innovation where your resume
emerges as a testament to your cyber
security Acumen in an era defined by
persistent threats standing out
necessitates more than just knowledge it
demands tangible experience raise
yourself as we explore the top five
cyber security projects that will
transform your resume into a fortress of
expertise project one vulnerability
assessment tool a vulnerability
assessment tool is a computer security
software application that scans and
tests a computer system or network for
potential vulnerabilities and weaknesses
vulnerability assessment tools work by
simulating attacks on a system to
identify any security holds that could
be exploited by attackers imagine
building a Cutting Edge tool that craws
networks fiting out weaknesses with
unparalleled Precision craft a
vulnerability assessment tool that not
only identifies potential threats but
also recommend robust Solutions
showcasing your adeptness in preeptive
threat mitigation project two secure
encryption algorithm secure encryption
algorithms are algorithms used to
encrypt data in such a way that only
authorized parties with a correct key or
password can access the information
these algorithms are an important part
of digital security as they help to
protect sensitive data from unauthorized
access theft or disclosure what's cyber
security without an unbreakable
Interruption Fortress design a
cryptographic Marvel that Shields
sensitive information from crying eyes
demonstrate your Mastery in safeguarding
data Integrity through an improv
encryption algorithm project three
incident response simulation an incident
response simulation is a type of
security exercise that simulates a real
world incident response process the goal
of an incident response simulation is to
test an organization's ability to handle
a security incident by simulating a
realistic scenario and assessing how
effectively the organization can respond
to it dive into the world of Controlled
Chaos
develop an incident response plan that
Rivals a military strategy orating rapid
responses to simulating cyber threats
showcase your ability to navigate crisis
scenarios with composure and precision
mitigating digital disasters
effectively project for penetration
testing framework penetration testing
pen testing is a controlled simulation
of attacks on a computer system or
Network to identify vulnerability and
weaknesses in its security architecture
a penetration testing framework is a
systematic approach to vend testing that
defines the steps and processes to be
followed the objectives and scope of the
test and the tools and techniques to be
used the art of ethical hacking takes
Center Stage Forge of penetration
testing framework that not only
identifies system weaknesses but also
trans Ates them into strengths showcase
your progress in transforming
vulnerabilities into opportunities for
fortified defense project five security
automation script a security automation
script is a piece of code or a set of
instructions that can be executed on a
Computing system to automate security
related tasks and Operations Security
automation scripts are used to automate
repetive and routine security task to
centralize the management of security
controls and to improve security posture
by reducing the time and effort required
to perform security operations witness
the Symphony of automation develop a
script that cographs security protocols
reducing human error while amplifying
system efficiency illustrate your knck
for streamlining operations and
enhancing security through Innovative
automation these top five cyber security
projects aren't mere accomplishments
they are Testament to your commitment to
safeguarding digital Landscapes elevate
your career by showcasing these projects
signaling that you're not just a cyber
security Enthusiast but a stalwart
guardian of digital Integrity staying
ahead in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here